hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round nine of the
feed hs dot com grand swiss it's nils
grandelius versus fabiano caruana and
there were a lot of games to choose from
uh from round nine but i decided to show
this one as it's a great prelude to what
comes in round 10 but we're gonna
discuss this after we check out the game
there's quite a lot to cover it's a very
very interesting end game so let's enjoy
it and sorry if i say some nonsense from
time to time we have a new baby in the
house and i'm really not getting all
that much sleep so sometimes maybe i you
know uh go places uh that being said uh
let's check out the game so agundelius
with the white pieces opens with e4 uh
we have c5 going for the sicilian
defense knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 niels goes for the annie's
medina rossolimo attack uh we have e6
castles and the knight g to e7 preparing
knight to g6 so rook to e1 and knight to
g6 so this is what we've been playing
before nothing out of the ordinary here
uh quran is preparing bishop to e7 and
d5 and white as usual wants to play c3
and d4
so uh c3 we have a6 challenging the
bishop here bishop all the way back to
f1 uh to be used uh
later on and bishop to e7 we have d4
white strikes in the center we have
captures captures and now black strikes
in the center with d5 and here the usual
idea is just e5 grabbing more space in
the center yeah but the candle is place
e captures on d5 uh so this is a very
very early trade e captures on d5 and
now knight to c3 the downside being that
black just has a very natural way of
developing his bishop there is no longer
a pawn on e6 so you can play bishop to
a6 and you you you are very happy uh so
here we have castles by fabi and bishop
to e3 we have bishop to e6 although
bishop to g4 might seem more active
after h3
the bishop really has no purpose here
you can't go to h5 because of g4 and you
really don't want to trade your bishop
for a knight here so you just have to go
back so of course instead we just put it
to e6 right away
and now uh there is a game where uh a
move a3 was played but here we have
knights the a4 and it is now only as of
move 13 that we have a completely new
game uh so let's see what fabi does fog
plays bishop to b4 here white wants to
play some like rook to c1 he wants to
play a3 b4 put the knight not there put
the knight on c5 and enjoy his position
so uh fabi uh tries bishop to b4 first
attacks the rook and now if you go back
then knight to a4 didn't really make
much sense so here we have bishop back
to d2 uh and the queen to d6 developing
the bishop the uh defending the bishop
developing the queen and connecting your
rook so here we have bishop captures on
b4 queen captures on b4 and now h3 and
now what do you play here uh it seems
like you could play b5 kick away the
knight and win the b2 pawn but this
doesn't really work after b5 uh white is
more than happy with knight to c5
because now you're attacking the bishop
twice and of course if queen captures on
b2 we can start harassing the queen
let's say queen a3 rook to e3 queen to
a5 and now we capture on e6 we pick up
the pawn and we've equalized the
material and we of course have a better
position now so instead we have rook 8
the e8 uh not bringing this rook into
the game but rather this one because we
plan to move the bishop and
of course the knight is coming to c5
will attack the bishop and we want to
play bishop to c8 but we don't want to
play bishop to c8 while our rook is
still on a8 we want to have our rooks
connected so that's why fabi brings this
rook to ae8 uh and now knight to c5
attacks the bishop puts pressure on the
b7 pawn and just bishop back to c8 so
now offering a trade of rooks uh which
uh grand daley's goes for we have rook
capture 78 rook captures and queen to b3
now offering a trade of queens uh so
what do you play here uh fabi decides
it's time to trade we have not a queen
captures knight captures and now f6 as
fabi no longer has a dark square bishop
uh he has a light square bishop so it
makes sense to put your pawns in dark
squares later on you can play king f7
you can push those pawns and also you
are really restricting the movements of
this knight on f3 there are no more
squares left for this knight it's going
to have to do something else so rook to
c1 now if this knight moves maybe we can
bring a rook over to c7 so knight g to
e7
and now comes a3 we have king to f7 and
now the shutter d3 putting pressure on
the h7 pawn so just h6 now fabi is
preparing g5
and white starts bringing the king into
the game king to f1 with g5 and now like
we said this knight really has nothing
to do here so just knight back to g1 now
you can shift it to e2 to c3 and then
maybe to
a4 and then bring this knight to c5 for
the moment this knight can't really move
as you would lose the d4 pawn so here h5
fabi just grabs more space on the king's
side knight to the e2 and then now h4 so
just grabbing more space putting our
pawns on dark squares we have knights to
c3 and now even f5 so that's really
really grabbing more space and now uh
white abandons the plan of shifting the
knight over to the queen side and now
goes back knights to e2 now this knight
will be defending the d4 pawn and this
knight can maybe go to d2 maybe to f3
maybe put some pressure on g5 control e5
and so on so king to f6 by fabi and now
knight to d2 uh and now knight to d8 now
the knight is coming to e6 where it will
be nicely controlling the c5 square but
also
many other squares here and you don't
really care about rook to c7 or if white
plays this we just kick it away and the
rook really has no no place being there
so after knight to d8 we have rook to c3
and now comes bishop to d7 we have
knight to b3 again with ideas of maybe
knight to c5 now comes knight to e6
regarding the c5 square and the white
very happily goes for this trade knight
to c5 we have knight captures on c5 and
now you could capture with the rook you
could capture with the pawn uh but
capturing with the pawn it doesn't seem
like you'll be able to push those spawns
and create some sort of a pass pawn with
this bishop controlling all of these
light squares so instead grendelus goes
for rook captures on c5 and now king to
e6 putting uh
a king to e6 to defend the d5 pawn so if
knight to c3 you don't have to worry
and now just rook back to c3 it's
interesting you could go for something
like
knights the g1 to c3 here but the
problem is if knight g1 we can play
knight c6 and now if knight the c3 king
to d6 and now you can't pick up the pawn
here because we pick up the d4 pawn and
then even the rook would be hanging so
white abandons this idea of
re-maneuvering the knight for the moment
and brings the rogue back rook to c3 now
you could play some like rook to b3 you
could play b4 uh and here king to d6 and
now rook to b3 so attacking the pawn
here and uh corona advances it to b5 and
now the only way for white to
uh will play this uh with absolute
precision is to play a4 here uh it's a
temporary pawn sacrifice but it's not
one that uh you know uh is is uh
is good for black uh because if b
captures on a4 you can play rook to b6
check and after the king moves you're
gonna pick up the a6 pawn and now after
rook the b8 going after the b2 pawn yes
the a4 pawn is defended but you don't
care you're gonna play knight to c3 and
now if black captures here we can
capture on a4 and it's not a problem uh
so this is what uh white should go for
however in the game we have rook to c3
and now knight to c6 by fabian now it's
much much different uh this knight
really now controls a lot of squares for
example this knight cannot move because
the the pawn falls so here white's idea
is to play b4 and now uh corona plays f4
so you're grabbing even more space on
the king side
and what do you play here well we have
bishop to g6 attacking the rook rook to
a8 now preparing to push uh the pawn to
a5 and now king the e1
niels wants to improve the uh
activity of his king but here there was
the very interesting rook to c5 it
prevents pawn to a5 because if ponte a5
now we can play knight to c3 and now
what do you do about this d5 pawn also
b5 pawn is hanging so here you you're
just going to have to trade and after
captures with czech king to e7 and now a
capture sun b4 knight captures on b for
even rook captures and g5 and here it
would be well it's only white that can
be better here he's up upon he has a
very active position uh so after rook to
c5 you would actually have to play some
like bishop to e6 to first defend your
pawn and then at some point of course
you will be able to play a5 so maybe a
slight improvement to white nils played
uh the king the e1 uh move uh as fabinho
immediately advances the pawn to a5 we
have b captures on a5 knight captures on
a5 he wants to bring the knight to c4 to
really put pressure on that a3 pawn uh
and now knight to g1 now the knight is
coming to f3 and then going after the g5
pawn
so knight to c4 going after the a3 pawn
knight to a f3 and now knight captures
an a3 we have knight captures on g5 so
the material is still equal
and now knight to c4 yeah and here we
have a very interesting move and that is
knight to f7 check uh
checking the black king asking what do
you play now but this is one check that
should never have been played because
here it would seem that fabi's position
is completely winning but it's unclear
why so try and figure it out feel free
to pause the video here and what do you
play here with black while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations as you really
are a true master of the end game and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show uh king the e7 is what fabi
played but this is not the winning idea
the winning idea is king to e6 and we're
going to discuss this just a little bit
because after king to e7 uh you don't
have a sufficient control over the e5
square after you play king to e6 uh yeah
you don't really have knights to e5 the
thing is if knight to e5 now we simply
play rook to a1 with check and now after
the king moves we can play b4 we
challenge the rook here after the rook
moves now we play knight captures on e5
and after d captures an e5 bishop to b5
with check and look at this rook bishop
combo
it's very very uh difficult to get out
of this one and it's it's very hard to
imagine such things from the moment
where white delivered that check where a
single king square would allow you to
execute such a brilliant attack for
example if king d2 rook a2 checked and
now after king to e1 we can even play
rook to e2 with check and if king d2 now
we play rook captures on f2 and now
we're going to gobble up all of these
pawns here if rook captures here we're
going to play bishop to c4 everything is
nicely defended we're capturing this
we're capturing this
we are completely winning here so after
king the e6 you don't really have this
knight to the e5 idea but you don't have
many other moves either because well
king is coming to f6 so you could play
some like rook to f3 attack this pawn
but still king of six if you capture
here we capture the bishop and if bishop
to h5 now we have this rook to e8 check
king to d1 and now rook to e4 defending
this pawn and attacking this pawn and
there's nothing for white to do here if
something like king c2 even bishop to e8
is just a winning material and it's a
game over on the spot so incredible how
after knight to f7 check uh the the game
is basically over if you play king e6
but fabi missed this he played king to
e7 uh and now the e5 square is available
for the knight so of course the
granddale use goes for this with knight
to e5 and now uh capturing doesn't
really do all that much for you if you
capture we're going to play d captures
and kink the e6 now runs into the
unpleasant rook to c7 so it's a very uh
you know uh difficult position to play
if rook to d8 defending the bishop
preparing to capture on e5 we're going
to play rook to b7
so what do you play here king captures
on e5 now bishop to d3 and now we go
after the pawn here there's no real way
for black to defend the bishop c6 we
just move the rook and capture on b5
next uh it's again going to be equal
material with black controlling a bit
more space but it shouldn't be enough to
win the game so instead after this uh
knights the e5 we have b4 of course you
have to play this at some point in the
game uh the rook has to move now rook to
b3 and now rook to a1 with check so the
only way for fabi to really uh
gain some sort of an initiative comes
with the sacrifice of the b4 pawn but
many great things in chess usually come
with the sacrifice of the b4 pawn so
here we have king to e2 rook to a2 with
check king to e1 repeating the position
a little bit rook day one check king e2
and now bishop to a4 not the bishop to
b5 it seems like a very dangerous move
but the bishop can simply block with
bishop to d3 so bishop to a4 now forcing
the rook to capture on b4 and then we
get this bishop to d1 check in so here
rook captures on b4 bishop to d1 check
and now king to e1 uh if you go if you
go up the board it's game over just rook
a3 check and you have no moves you have
to play rook b3 and this is just
checkmate all of the squares here are
covered as you can see so after bishop
to d1 king the e1 was played and now we
have bishop to c2 with check opening up
a discovery to this bishop but it's not
really all that impressive the bishop is
defended so here we have king to e2 and
uh now it doesn't really matter if you
capture uh for example on e5 we're gonna
capture on c2 so it doesn't really work
if you capture on on g6 we're gonna just
recapture here so fabio repeats bishop
d1 check king to e1 and now knight
captures an e5 and now it's a problem if
you capture the knight then bishop the c
to check is winning we're we're gonna
pick up this bishop so king d2 bishop
captures yes you will have rook captures
on f4 and you will have two pawns for
for the uh for the bishop but it's still
with perfect play should be should be a
win for black um if uh you know
especially with with someone like fabi
playing so instead after knight captures
on e5 rook the b1 was played an
excellent resource by nils uh just uh
blocking the
uh the rook's attacked towards the king
now there are no discoveries with the
bishop uh and what do you play here uh
it's a really really tricky position
there's only one move that wins you the
game so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this incredible
idea for fabi while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not playing
anything weird like d captures on e5 and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show the move of course is f3 that's
the good stuff um
and uh
we're gonna discuss this uh if you play
something like uh
sorry uh no it's not d captures on e5 if
you play something like rook captures uh
on a1
uh after f3 uh sorry about that yeah
this is what i mean sometimes i just uh
you know
lose uh uh the the idea of what i'm
doing so the idea here of course is f3
and now the point is you cannot capture
the rook because f captures on g2 and
there's simply no no stopping this pawn
we're just going to promote this pawn to
a queen
so you're going to have to figure out
something else after f3 the only way to
continue the game is g captures on f3
and now or okay you could play king to
f1 that's also possible but it's uh much
too easy for black we're just going to
capture here and after the king captures
we're going to play bishop to f3 with
check and after the king moves we're
going to play captures with check bishop
captures and now play knight to c6 and
we're just going to pick up this pawn
we're going to be completely winning
this we're up a piece uh white has no
pawns you know as compensation so
instead after f3 g captures on f3 the
only way for niels to continue playing
this game and now knight captures on g6
uh rook captures on a1 and the bishop
captures on f3 and now fabi has two
pieces for a rook
and well very very good chances of
winning this game so king d2 we have
bishop to e4 king to e3 and now bishop
to f5 going after the h3 pawn so we have
to defend this rook to h1 and now king
to f6 we have rook to h2 and now uh
knight to h8 uh this knight the h8 i
don't think really has a purpose i think
it's sort of a waiting move as
this is move 60 and you you get
additional time when you when you hit 60
moves so i believe this is just you know
reaching time control as the they were
both very much low on the clock so here
we have f3 fabi brings the knight back
knight to g6 rook to h1 and now bishop
to e6 so you have to figure out some
sort of way of actually winning uh the
h3 pawn so rook h2 now comes knight to
e7 king to f4 and now knights to f5
attacking the d4 pawn so rook to d2
defending the pawn is now the bishop
can't capture the knight is on f5 and
now bishop to d7 asking white what do
you play here and now you have to play
uh play a move and
it has to be a move that allows this
rook to kind of go back to the h file to
defend the the pawn if the knight moves
so rook the d1 was played but now
knight's the g3 and now there's really
nothing you can do to defend the pawn
we're going to capture with the bishop
and the knight covers the h1 square but
glendale is still very resourceful he
plays rook to d2 and now just prepares
rook to h2 now if the pawn is captured
you can play rook to h2 and now after
the bishop moves you can simply pick up
the pawn and it's very unlikely that
black will be able to win this so fabi
has to thread very carefully here knight
to h5 check king to e3 and now came to
g5 and he was in this position on move
68 uh that
and niels grendell is resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
so the thing is uh if you play some like
rook g2 check we simply block with the
knight then we pick up the
pawn here on h3 if you defend the knight
f1 check just picks up the rook so of
course that's not possible so you can't
really start with rook to g to check you
could start with rook to h2 now the pawn
is defended but now we simply play
knight to f4 attack the pawn once again
and after you make a move because you
have to make one move we can simply
capture it bishop captures on h3 and
that's it let's say king f2 we're gonna
play bishop back to e6 make room for our
past pawn if king g1 we're gonna play
knight to d3 and you know whatever rook
to a3 attacks the knight knight before
we can harass the knight a little bit
knight to c to go after this spawn rook
to d3 defending now bishop to f5
attacking the the rook here after rook
to d2 uh we can even play h3 so it's
perfectly fine the king is coming to 4
to g3 and it's game over
uh so after king to g5 and move 68 and
granddale is resigned and a very very
impressive victory for fabiana corona
who will now face uh uh
alireza furuja on board one in round 10
and we're gonna have the clash that we
were waiting for this entire tournament
as fabi is the the the top seed of the
tournament and it uh took 10 rounds for
him to be paired with alireza as alireza
was constantly leading the tournament
and fabi was always like a point uh
behind the half a point behind so it's
only now that we get to this uh clash
it's fabi with the white pieces alireza
will be having black uh and it should be
uh should be quite quite the game uh if
alireza can win against fabi with black
then no doubt he already wins the
tournament probably around before the
tournament actually ends uh but even if
uh it's a draw or if fabi wins uh
because uh fabi has a guaranteed
entrance to the defeated candidates
tournament so it doesn't matter if fabi
wins the tournament ifalreza gets like
second he still qualifies of course for
for the tournament as you know fabi
can't take away the spot from uh from
anyone else uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh once again
congratulations to everyone who spotted
both of the positive video moments or
even just one you know they were
incredibly difficult uh i would like to
wish a very happy birthday to chess hasi
and a very happy birthday uh to pair for
cell and i would like to thank david
lille tom darrell and muhammad ali for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and i will
see you soon uh continuing the coverage
of this amazing event checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day